Let me give you an example to motivate
why this vision of active networks is both intriguing
and interesting. You may all know that Diwali
is a big festival in India, just like Christmas
is in the Western world. And let's say
that I am sending Diwali greetings electronically to my
siblings, who are in India. What I can
do, is I can send individually a greeting message
to each of my siblings. And so, there'll be
N messages going out on the Internet from source
to destination. So I send out N messages, and,
you know, to reach any of my siblings. That's
one way of doing it. A nicer approach would
be, given that all my siblings are clustered in
one corner of the globe, it would be nice
if I could send just one message, traverses the Internet,
gets to close to the destination of where
my siblings are, and the router that is
at this end, demultiplexes my message and sends
it to all my siblings. Obviously, the second method
is more frugal in terms of using network
resources. I don't have to send N messages. I
can send one message, and finally at or
close to the destination, an active node takes this
one message, recognizes, oh, this is intended for multiple
recipients, and demultiplexes them, and sends it to all
the eventual recipients of this message. Of course, we
can generalize this idea and say that this idea of
active router is going to be spread out throughout
the Internet, so that even if my siblings, let's
say, are distributed all over the world, then I
could still send a single message from my source, and
it gets demultiplexed along the way, depending on
where all the eventual recipients are for this
particular message that starts from me. So in
other words, we can sprinkle this intelligence that
is in this one particular router to all the routers in the Internet and that way
we are making the entire Internet an active
network. That's the vision behind active networks where the
nodes in the internet will become, not
just passive entities, but actually active, in looking
at the message, and figuring out what to
do with it, in terms of routing decisions.